>>Dan Galpin: Nice.
>>Ian Ni-Lewis: All right.
Hi there.
Welcome to the Friday Games Review.
I am your host, Ian Ni-Lewis.
Wait!
No, we totally switched off, right?
>>Galpin: We totally switched off.
>>Ni-Lewis: I'm not the host anymore.
>>Galpin: That's okay.
>>Ni-Lewis: God, I'm not the host anymore.
>>Galpin: Actually, according to the titles,
you're Dan Galpin and I'm Ian Ni-Lewis.
>>Ni-Lewis: Did I get that wrong?!
>>Galpin: I know, I know.
Ah.
Wait, [laughs] hold on.
[rustling sounds] I just dropped my mike,
so everyone's going, "Oh no, this rustling
sound!"
>>Ni-Lewis: Nice.
It's okay, dude, don't complain on YouTube!
We've heard it all before.
>>Galpin: Yeah, exactly.
>>Ni-Lewis: I can't believe I did that.
You know why?
'Cause I'm left-right challenged.
>>Galpin: Oooookay, okay.
Here we go.
>>Ni-Lewis: It's because I come from a mirror
universe.
>>Galpin: That makes sense, that makes sense.
Yeah, that would explain a lot, actually.
>>Reto Meier: Actually, I'm pretty sure Dan's
from the mirror universe, 'cause he has the
Spock evil twin beard going.
>>Galpin: That's true.
>>Ni-Lewis: Dude, that's not the Spock evil
beard!
That's the plantation owner beard.
>>Galpin: Oh, that's what that is.
Yeah, I see.
>>Ni-Lewis: In fact, this shouldn't say Dan
Galpin, it should say Colonel Dan Galpin.
>>Galpin: That's right.
It does look kinda like Colonel Sanders, doesn't
it?
>>Ni-Lewis: It does indeed, my friend.
>>Galpin: In his younger years, before it
came up in 11 herbs and spices.
All right.
>>Ni-Lewis: Right.
It was nine herbs and spices back then.
Speaking of herbs and spices--
>>Galpin: They discovered the other two at
that point.
>>Ni-Lewis: [laughs] Let's bring in our special
guest.
[pause]
>>Galpin: Special gue--?
Oh!
Yes, absolutely.
>>Ni-Lewis: We have a special guest every
week.
>>Galpin: Special guest, I know.
>>Ni-Lewis: So today, we are drinking Hoogstraten
Poorter.
>>Galpin: Oooooh.
>>Ni-Lewis: Which may or may not be good.
I don't know.
>>Galpin: All right.
>>Ni-Lewis: You can see it's-- the bottle
is resealable.
>>Galpin: Ooooh.
>>Ni-Lewis: So if we don't drink it all--
>>Galpin: That's right.
>>Ni-Lewis: That's [laughs] that's a useless
expense.
>>Galpin: That's not going to happen.
Yeah.
>>Ni-Lewis: That's pretty needless right there.
We have some great apps today.
Dan and Co talked last time, and they're like,
"Screw this whole theme thing."
>>Galpin: That's right.
>>Ni-Lewis: "We're just going to go with whatever
the viewers want."
>>Galpin: Exactly.
>>Ni-Lewis: And by viewers, we mean whoever
had enough friends to nominate something and
get it voted up.
We've got some good stuff today, I think.
Oh, and we also have our new high tech title
system.
Watch this.
[pause] Whee!
>>Galpin: Oooooh.
>>Ni-Lewis: So that's what we're going to
watch.
That's what we're going to talk about today.
And I have to-- Oh yeah, yeah.
I'm supposed to be sitting over here.
Right.
>>Galpin: Right, I know, I know.
This is all challenging.
All right.
>>Ni-Lewis: No, we're totally good, we're
totally good.
We just have less space.
So, we're talking-- we're going to be talking
about Pearls Deluxe, Asuri Tower Defense,
Sacracy RPG, Patentia, and Offroad Legends.
That's a lot to get through, so let's start
up our super duper sports center title sequence.
Okay, well, that's all there is.
>>Galpin: What?
>>Ni-Lewis: But I totally downloaded the demo
version of Aftereffects last night.
>>Galpin: Yeah?
>>Ni-Lewis: So if I get some time over the
weekend, who knows what amazing things might
happen?
>>Galpin: There might be some amazing, cool
stuff.
All right.
I've now put them on in the right order here.
>>Ni-Lewis: [beer glugs] Your beer, sir.
>>Galpin: There we are.
>>Ni-Lewis: All right.
>>Galpin: Oh!
>>Ni-Lewis: Indeed.
Okay, so let's start with Pearls Deluxe.
Now, Pearls Deluxe is a game that reminds
me a lot of something I've seen before.
Did we play Pearls the non-Deluxe version
at some point, or?
>>Galpin: I don't know.
I thought you were going to say, "Pearls Deluxe
has got the most washed out looking feature
graphic that I've ever seen."
>>Ni-Lewis: That is an issue, yeah.
You may-- A lot of things about this feature
graphic are good.
It's definitely legible.
>>Galpin: Yeah.
Yeah.
>>Ni-Lewis: But it's-- it could maybe--
>>Galpin: It looks like it's been-- Not only
does it look washed out, but also, it looks
like it's just been scaled up rather than
scaled down, which--
>>Ni-Lewis: Oh, really?
>>Galpin: Yeah.
>>Ni-Lewis: Well, that may actually be my
fault.
I may have actually put it on a different
resolution.
>>Galpin: No, no, I looked at it on Google.
>>Ni-Lewis: Oh, okay.
All right.
>>Galpin: It's kinda fuzzy looking.
>>Ni-Lewis: All right.
So obviously, a great feature graphic is important.
But it's particularly important if you want
to get featured.
>>Galpin: Yes.
>>Ni-Lewis: Now, let's talk about Pearls Deluxe.
So Pearls Deluxe ended up being a really fun
game, I think.
>>Galpin: Absolutely.
>>Ni-Lewis: Do you play it much?
Oh, it doesn't support--
>>Galpin: Yeah, we're going to play--
>>Ni-Lewis: We're going to just put this down,
I think.
>>Galpin: Play it like that, just so we don't
jiggle the HDMI, 'cause it's-- Okay.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yep.
Oh, that's funny.
I put it down at an angle, and then I looked
at this, and I thought, "Oh no!
How-- wait.
How is that at an angle?"
And it's just the way it works.
So yeah.
Pearls Deluxe is a-- it's a slight twist on
your typical bubble popping game.
>>Galpin: Yeah.
Actually, I think it's a pretty significant
twist.
Basically, what you have to do is create sequences
of paths that have to cover all of the dots--
you can't-- all of the pearls that are the
same color that are touching each other, but
also have to be in a line that goes straight
through without any turns or diagonals.
So, it's impossible to pick up--
>>Ni-Lewis: Well, without any backtracking,
yes.
>>Galpin: Without any backtracking.
It's impossible.
>>Ni-Lewis: So for instance, this one you
can't do.
>>Galpin: You can't do.
>>Ni-Lewis: Uh-uh!
>>Galpin: Uh-uh!
Exactly.
>>Ni-Lewis: And they have a really, really
cute sound effects that we can't play because
of the man.
All right.
>>Galpin: Exactly.
Ooh, there's a big one over there on the--
>>Ni-Lewis: There is?
Oh, let's see.
Ooooh, yeah.
Nice!
Okay.
Yeah.
So what I like about this twist is that it's
not just a change in the way it's played from
a mechanics level.
It does affect your strategy deeply.
>>Galpin: Yeah, absolutely.
And it's-- You can definitely screw yourself
up and get to a point where's there's just
nothing you can pop anymore, if you're not
careful.
Also, there's a timer throughout the game,
as we just saw.
So just some general comments about the game:
1.
This is an example of what happens when you
don't actually look at the ad on a tablet
device.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
Your ad network is probably not going to be
happy with you for that.
>>Galpin: I think it's more of a-- You're
probably-- People aren't even going to know
that it is-- Maybe they'll get some clicks
that way, I don't know.
But I suspect you'll get fewer clicks if people
can't read the ad.
But you never know.
I never know what really works with these
things.
So that's definitely one thing to look at.
Now, what is the share button do?
I didn't actually try it.
I'm a little bit terrified.
>>Ni-Lewis: Well, that is a share intent,
actually.
>>Galpin: It is a share intent.
That's good.
>>Ni-Lewis: But you've also got a Facebook
button.
>>Galpin: Which takes you to the website.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
We're not super thrilled with that.
And let me be really clear: it has nothing
to do with the particular social network.
If this was a Google+ button, we would feel
exactly the same way.
It's just [pause] there's already a share
intent, and adding extra stuff on there, especially
something that's going to take you out of
the game and launch a web browser, which is
almost always going to take a long time to
start up, and it uses battery, and it uses
data.
Why?
>>Galpin: Yeah, it's one of the things where
it's also a question of where you want to
actually launch it in an external browser,
launch it in a web view.
I don't even know what you wanted to do in
this case.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah, it's like-- And the thing
is, part of it is the fact that there's already
the share intent available, but I understand
that there's a difference between liking something
or +1ing something and sharing it.
But if you look at how these buttons work
on websites, when you +1 something, or when
you like something, that's a single action.
You just press that button and you're done.
It's supposed to be a very, very lightweight
action.
But here, you've changed something that's
supposed to be lightweight, and you've made
it extremely heavyweight.
>>Galpin: Exactly, exactly.
I completely agree with you.
>>Ni-Lewis: Basically, I liked you when I
press that button, but by the time the web
browser launched, I no longer like you.
>>Galpin: Exactly.
You just have to be that much more enthusiastic
about the game to actually get to the liking
phase.
>>Ni-Lewis: Exactly.
It is a pretty good game, though.
>>Galpin: It is, it is.
In general, it behaves reasonably well.
Nothing wrong with this.
>>Ni-Lewis: All right.
>>Galpin: So in terms of what happens when
you press the back key here.
Reasonable.
Again, it looks like a dialog, and there we
are.
Back at our home screen.
So not too bad.
>>Ni-Lewis: Now, in sharp contrast to that,
let's take a look at our next game.
So Asuri Tower Defense, I have to admit, it
reeeeally got my hopes up.
>>Galpin: You are a tower defense fanatic.
>>Ni-Lewis: I love tower defense!
And when I saw--
>>Galpin: This is the man who purchased tons
and tons of items in Radiant Defense.
>>Ni-Lewis: I purchased every item in Radiant
Defense.
Absolutely.
Got every upgrade.
So I would love to have a game like that again.
I still play Radiant Defense sometimes.
I'm up to 13 million.
>>Galpin: Exactly.
So you have the right reviewer here for this
one, is what I'm saying.
>>Ni-Lewis: And then I looked at the feature
graphic and I'm like, "That looks pretty promising.
That's got some nice-- It's a little dated,
but not bad."
I looked at this, and I'm like, "Whoa, hell
yeah!"
Asuri TD is an awesome new strategic tower
defense game filled with action.
Asuri Tower Defense is an awesome new tower
defense game.
Okay.
It's the unique strategy game and full of
action.
>>Galpin: You'll never have a dull moment
while playing it.
You may have other tower defense games--
>>Ni-Lewis: [yelling] But Asuri is the ultimate
tower defense game and brings you to places
with a unique story mode! [normal voice] I
was excited.
>>Galpin: We love the idea that if you repeat
a keyword a whole bunch in the description,
it's more likely to be found by us.
>>Ni-Lewis: That's not actually true now.
>>Galpin: It's not.
>>Ni-Lewis: It's actually less likely, because
we think it's spam.
But here's the thing--
>>Galpin: The general thing: don't do it.
>>Ni-Lewis: I think you could forgive me for
getting my hopes up once I read this.
Now, once I read the--
>>Galpin: I read it and I looked at it.
Why are they spelling "tower defense" multiple
ways within their description?
Maybe--
>>Ni-Lewis: My guess is they're from India
and they're-- they've still got a bunch of
leftovers from their former British masters.
>>Galpin: Well, it was interesting to me.
They spelled it both ways.
And I was thinking, maybe they wanted to make
sure they got both keywords or something.
>>Ni-Lewis: It's possible.
Yeah.
>>Galpin: But our system is smart.
I don't think that's actually necessary.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
In any case, I got to the part about the story
plot, and I'm like, "Oh, a story plot."
And then it says, "The story is about a hero
and Rose, they travel through space and time,
they start to like each other."
That's "hmmm."
And then I read the reviews.
And here's where it got interesting for me.
>>Galpin: Okay, okay.
>>Ni-Lewis: I read the reviews and I noticed
they had a very good rating.
>>Galpin: Okay.
>>Ni-Lewis: I noticed that there are two reviews
left by random people with random names that
say, "This game is not worth your time.
It's absolute rubbish."
Okay.
There are then three reviews that are extremely
complementary, all of which have Indian names.
>>Galpin: Ah!
Okay.
Well, maybe it's just designed to appeal to
that demographic.
>>Ni-Lewis: That is completely possible.
Or it might very well be that the dude's Indian,
and--
>>Galpin: The demographic of their friends,
exactly.
It could be.
That happens.
If you have a small enough sample set, your
friends can actually alter the--
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
I guess what I'm saying is if you're going
to pack reviews with your friends, make sure
that they've got distinctive names, instead
of just-- The same family name, that's a tip-off.
Anyway, let's take a look at the game.
Now, the thing about tower defense-- Oh, now
this is where it goes wrong.
Can you take my overlay off?
[pause] Beautiful.
See, that's what we get for having a professional
engineer.
>>Galpin: You can get rid of us, actually,
momentarily.
'Cause I think people should-- [game music
playing] --screen without our faces-- No!
We're back!
>>Ni-Lewis: There are some--
>>Meier: You did say "momentarily."
>>Galpin: [laughs] [game music playing]
>>Ni-Lewis: Unfortunately, they're further
behind [game music playing] that I would probably
like.
It's covered with these gigantic, fake, Comic
Sans, bubbly, in a sort of 1995 way buttons,
which is just horrible.
And they've got their own take on the blink
tag.
So kudos there.
There's also something on the title screen
that says, "When experiencing lag in game,
consider to turn off music and/or sound by
clicking sound icons."
[pause]
>>Galpin: Are those the icons here, or are
those the icons in the game?
I think this may be the--
>>Ni-Lewis: I don't care.
I don't care at all.
This is an ugly title screen.
Fix it.
You need to fix that.
You've also reused the exact same set of 9-patches,
apparently, for-- Or is that even 9-patches?
I'm not sure.
For these buttons on the left- and right-hand
side of the screen, where they look very inappropriate.
>>Galpin: The big button on the left that
says back is kinda pointless, isn't it?
>>Ni-Lewis: This is one of the cases that
we've said that just because you got yourself
a demo copy of Photoshop and you know how
to use the gradient tool, does not mean that
you're going to make a beautiful glass UI.
It's a lot easier to put together something
that looks like this.
>>Galpin: I'm totally betting on the gimp
right now.
>>Ni-Lewis: You think this is a gimp?
Oh, yeah.
>>Galpin: But anyways.
>>Ni-Lewis: It doesn't have a cheesy embossing
effect, at least.
And then, they have a start here--
>>Galpin: [unintelligible]
>>Ni-Lewis: They have a start here, which
is nice, because I wouldn't have known, although
I will say that the blue arrow here, below
the start here button, is almost invisible.
>>Galpin: I do kinda like the effect, the
pixelation effect, they've got going over
there.
>>Ni-Lewis: So this is kinda cool.
Definitely needs some-- a little bit of thinking
about fonts.
>>Galpin: Actually, I would just like it to
be rendering the font on the device.
>>Ni-Lewis: Right, that would help too.
>>Galpin: That actually would make a huge
difference in all of these things.
You may not be able to tell out there in viewer
land, but the font is really low res.
>>Ni-Lewis: You know, it's interesting.
I actually-- That slipped past me, and this
whole time I've been thinking, "Well, I guess
it makes sense that the fonts look crappy
because I must just not be looking at it at
the resolution it was offered."
>>Galpin: Oh, okay.
>>Ni-Lewis: But no.
They actually baked these fonts in.
>>Galpin: Yeah.
>>Ni-Lewis: So this is great.
Again, you need to have a designer on this.
[pause]
>>Galpin: [unintelligible]
>>Ni-Lewis: Okay, this is-- Again, some really--
You know, here, for instance--
>>Galpin: Now we have high res fonts, which
is cool.
>>Ni-Lewis: So we've got a lot of text here
that is not well planned out.
For instance, "resources", the word is actually
broken in--
>>Galpin: Yeah.
>>Ni-Lewis: Right?
>>Galpin: I guess-- I don't even know what
to say about this, other than "Wow."
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
When you actually get into the game, again,
we've got a weird mix of somewhat attractive
graphics and things that aren't attractive
at all.
It's not at all apparent how I start the game.
I seem to remember that I finally clicked
over here.
And then I'm going to build some stuff here.
Build some towers.
>>Galpin: It seems like it was an amazing
amount of text to not tell you anything useful
about-- Oh I guess you don't have any more
funds left to build.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
Right, right.
Now, in this case, there's a couple of things
that I have to object to.
The individual pieces of art are okay.
The animation is disappointing.
The [pause] death graphics are kinda cool.
You've got a little explosion.
But you'll notice they don't remove the sprite
until after the explosion animation finishes,
which completely breaks the--
>>Galpin: It'd be so much cooler to fade the
sprite out during the explosion, at least.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah, absolutely.
Generally, you should be-- what you really
want to do is take your sprite, get rid of
the unit sprite as soon as it dies, and replace
it with something else, whether it's the explosion,
or something that shows it breaking up, or
something that fades out, or whatever.
Also, these laser beams, I'm not buying 'em.
They're not exciting.
These things aren't taking damage in any obvious
way.
Even the health bars are very, very hard to
see.
And some--
>>Galpin: I like the little explosions when
they reach your base, though.
That's kinda cool.
>>Ni-Lewis: It is cool, but it'd be great--
I mean, they completely cover the unit.
Why isn't the unit being removed under cover
of that explosion?
>>Galpin: I agree.
>>Ni-Lewis: It's odd.
>>Galpin: It's odd because a lot of these
things seem really easy to do.
>>Ni-Lewis: Right.
>>Galpin: It's like, this is fairly-- Forget
you got this really cool little water effect
there on the other side, which I'm sure someone
spent a little bit of time actually thinking
about doing.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
I mean, it feels like they've got some talent,
but it's just very, very uneven.
And when I played this on my Nexus 7, it actually
had an interesting bug where they would reach
the heart, here, which is the endpoint, and
actually just turn around and go back.
They wouldn't die until they got all the way
back.
>>Galpin: Wow.
That seems like that actually requires some
really interesting pathing.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
>>Galpin: That's cool, but odd.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah, indeed.
>>Galpin: Exactly.
I wonder if that's-- huh.
>>Ni-Lewis: Essentially, yeah.
This isn't grabbing me.
It's also-- It starts out very difficult,
and continues to be difficult, and then doesn't
really give you any payoff for that difficulty.
So I have to admit that while I love tower
defense games and I really wanted to like
this one, I didn't play past the first level.
>>Galpin: Ah.
So--
>>Ni-Lewis: If the second level's awesome,
mess with me--
>>Galpin: Well, I'm hoping that this story
actually continues on.
>>Ni-Lewis: I don't want the story.
Some guy falls in love with a girl.
I hate those things.
Stories.
>>Galpin: All right, all right.
That's that.
It sounds like there's the core of a lot of
ideas there that could be polished up into
the game.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
Now, this is probably a good time to mention
that our good friend and producer Alex is
online watching the YouTube video-- I have
to check, because last time he was getting
his email and stuff.
>>Galpin: Yeah, I know, I know.
>>Ni-Lewis: Producer Alex is sitting there,
bitter, because Dan finally showed up.
And so he didn't get to do the game show.
>>Galpin: Did you play his games, Alex?
>>Alexander Lucas: Yeah.
>>Ni-Lewis: No, but he grew a beard.
>>Lucas: I played them all too.
>>Galpin: Okay.
Well, comment: what did you think of Asuri
TD, because I didn't-- that was the one I
actually didn't have time to play.
>>Lucas: Pretty much everything Ian said.
One interesting thing they do have going for
them, though, is zero permissions.
>>Galpin: Nice!
>>Ni-Lewis: That is cool.
>>Galpin: All right.
A thumbs up to that.
>>Lucas: That's impressive.
>>Galpin: Thank you guys.
>>Ni-Lewis: By the way, Alex, we're not to
your left.
We're right in front of you.
Yeah, totally.
Okay.
All right.
So let's go-- Oh, actually, you know what?
I have to mention one other thing.
Asuri TD-- Now, this does not apply to the
full version, which, for all I know, is completely
different and better.
But, you know, whatever.
[pause] What is up with this icon?
You don't need to put the name of your app
in the icon.
>>Galpin: Yeah.
>>Ni-Lewis: That's sorta a waste of space.
>>Galpin: Could you go to the screen, Reto?
Just switch over to the tablet, because I
just want to show this icon off.
Because it is kinda special.
And I noticed the actual-- the Asuri TD paid
icon is actually pretty cool.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah, yeah.
It's all right.
>>Galpin: It looks better and it doesn't have
the name in there.
>>Ni-Lewis: Right.
The free one-- yeah.
It feels like--
>>Galpin: Does the menu look better too?
I'm curious.
You know?
>>Ni-Lewis: No, no.
It's exactly the same.
>>Galpin: Well, it doesn't have the "buy"
thing at the top, which makes it look better.
But yeah.
>>Ni-Lewis: Well, that's true.
Starting the-- yeah, yeah.
It's all the same.
>>Galpin: It is.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
Okay.
>>Galpin: Okay.
Anyways, just thought it'd be worth checking
out.
>>Ni-Lewis: All right.
Well, let's go ahead and move on, then, to
Sacracy, I guess.
Or "Sac-racey"?
I don't know?
>>Galpin: I'm going to go with "Sac-rahcy."
>>Ni-Lewis: Okay.
So Sacracy, apparently, is a location-based
action RPG.
Now, I didn't play this because, as an ethereal
being, I have no location.
But Dan did.
>>Galpin: Yeah.
This is going to be fun because-- I'm turning
on location here.
I didn't actually try the location.
[pause] [whispers] "Mock locations aren't
allowed.
Please disable mock."
All right.
I'm going to go to couch mode.
Come back!
All right.
Okay.
So I actually never got to see the location
software in the game.
I have no idea whether it has any relevance
to the gameplay.
It doesn't feel like it will, but that's just--
that being said, the game is set in this 16
bit styled fantasy world that we're looking
at here.
And it has--
>>Ni-Lewis: That's kinda cool.
>>Galpin: And it has touch controls that move
you ever so slowly through the board.
>>Ni-Lewis: Ooooh.
>>Galpin: And because of--
>>Ni-Lewis: So is this one of those games
that advertises there's like 30 hours of gameplay
and 29 of them are spent walking from one
place to another?
>>Galpin: Yeah.
And I'm here at this temple, and you see I
just killed off someone.
It doesn't actually go through explaining
how to actually play the game.
It has a tutorial that explains what you're
supposed to do next.
Like, as you go through, it's like, "All right,
now find this skeleton and kill him, but it
doesn't actually explain how.
It turns out--
>>Ni-Lewis: Isn't that just an old dude?
So it's like some random senior citizen that
you just killed?
>>Galpin: It's not clear why that guy was
attacking me.
He might--
>>Ni-Lewis: Oh, he was attacking you?
Is that what you're trying to go with?
>>Galpin: Yeah, yeah, he was actually.
>>Meier: That's his defense, anyway.
>>Galpin: Yeah.
Oh!
Now that looks like a zombie.
>>Ni-Lewis: Maybe a Frankenstein.
>>Galpin: It's kinda cool looking.
>>Ni-Lewis: Oh, no, no, it's like a zombie
knight, I think.
>>Galpin: It looks like I might have gotten
poisoned, 'cause I'm all green.
Anyways, the game mechanics are actually pretty
basic.
The graphics are definitely a combination.
They remind me of Ultima 5 or Ultima 6.
[unintelligible]
>>Ni-Lewis: You know what?
This is actually-- I think this is the first
game of sort that I've actually liked the
graphics, because usually, my attitude is,
"Okay, dude, if you're going to go retro,
go full retro" because if you go retro but
higher res, it just ends up looking stupid.
But these guys totally pulled it off.
It looks retro, and yet it's really high res
and it looks good.
>>Galpin: Yeah.
And you know, there's lots of really, really
nice touches in the graphics of this game.
>>Ni-Lewis: And I'm really digging that temple
that's right under my arm.
>>Galpin: Yeah.
>>Ni-Lewis: Move over so it gets-- so the
viewers can actually see it.
>>Galpin: Yeah.
>>Ni-Lewis: That looks cool.
>>Galpin: While the game did drive me crazy
with this actual play of the game and the
[slowed voice] very, very slow pacing of these
early scenes, and the semi-bewildered state
of what I'm supposed to be doing in the game--
>>Ni-Lewis: I assume you're supposed to be
killing everything, and then taking whatever's
not nailed down.
Can you go inside the temple?
>>Galpin: Not that I was able to actually
find out.
I tried doing it.
It didn't seem like I could go in the temple.
>>Ni-Lewis: Is that dude associated with the
temple?
Is it like a friar or something?
Don't kill him!
>>Galpin: No, I know.
That's the-- If he-- Now I know--
>>Ni-Lewis: Oh, okay.
>>Galpin: "Welcome.
What is it that leads you here?"
>>Ni-Lewis: [inhales]
>>Galpin: "You say there are resurrecting
creatures?
Just as it was predicted.
Only an ancient ritual can free us from this
horror.
I will beg the gods for help."
>>Ni-Lewis: I'm going to say right now: that
is pretty, and I love the font, but it's not
a font.
It's a bitmap.
And it's really, really small on this device.
>>Galpin: Yeah.
That's what-- Definitely.
It actually might be a font, but if it is,
it's being rendered really small.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
A little too small.
>>Galpin: I can't actually tell.
>>Ni-Lewis: The rest of the UI is actually,
I would say, it's as small as it possibly
could be, but it's not too small.
>>Galpin: Yeah, it actually works pretty well
in this screen.
What's kinda cool about this game-- and we'll
try not to lose HDMI in this.
Maybe we can't do it here.
--is that this game--
>>Ni-Lewis: Oh, no, yeah, you can't rotate
while you're--
>>Galpin: You can't rotate while-- So this
game will actually play in both portrait and
landscape.
It has to do with--
>>Ni-Lewis: Now, that's nice.
Yeah.
And it's-- I mean, why wouldn't a game like
this be able to do that?
>>Galpin: Absolutely.
Now, it does have audio on the lock screen.
I will say that.
Which was maybe kinda sad.
And the game--
>>Ni-Lewis: We've been beating that drum for
a looooong time.
>>Lucas: It has audio when you leave the application.
>>Ni-Lewis: Oh, yeah, yeah!
>>Galpin: Yeah, yeah.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah, there were a ton of people
complaining about this.
And this is an example of something-- Like,
we get really, really anal about things like
no audio in the lock screen.
There's good reasons for that, but nobody's
going--
>>Galpin: You should get really, really anal
about audio in the app.
>>Ni-Lewis: If you can't-- Yeah, you can't
kill the audio?
It's just playing all the time?
>>Galpin: Yeah.
If you don't exit and log out of the app,
it keeps going until the system accidentally
kills the app for whatever reason.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah, you might want to take care
of that.
I think it would actually boost your sales.
>>Galpin: The other thing to note is that
there is a theory, a way to get to other aspects
of your character without doing this, but
I couldn't find it.
There's a lot of controls that are sitting
underneath the menu key.
>>Ni-Lewis: Okay.
>>Galpin: And there's a lot of stuff here
underneath the menu key.
>>Ni-Lewis: And like Reto and I just pointed
out on the last show, on the App Clinic, using
the menu key is problematic because it is
implemented in different ways across different
devices.
So if you can get rid of it and move to either
an on-screen button or an action bar pattern,
or something else that is predictable, that's
what we would recommend at this point.
>>Galpin: Yeah.
I mean, given that you guys have a lot of
space, you could be using, to pull up these
kinds of--
>>Ni-Lewis: Well, and they've got eight freaking
other buttons too.
It's not like they're--
>>Galpin: No, exactly.
It's not like this is a menu that's devoid
of buttons.
But the main problem with this is that they're
just not very discoverable.
And it's actually kinda a pain to go here
to get to my inventory.
Now, there's supposedly a green jewel that
I can click on to get to the inventory.
I don't see it.
But--
>>Ni-Lewis: Green jewel.
>>Galpin: Green jewel.
[rustling sound] And this was the one.
>>Ni-Lewis: There's-- But that's not a-- It
looks like a talk thing.
>>Galpin: That's the chat.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah, it's the chat.
>>Galpin: Exactly.
So I'm not-- I don't--
>>Ni-Lewis: Well-- Oh, dude!
What if the color that you think is green
is actually what they think is red, dude?
>>Galpin: Yeah, I thought about that.
You click on here and you get to this backpack,
which is not the inventory.
Oh, but I can get to it that way?
>>Ni-Lewis: See, that's a problem.
Ideas that you come up with when you're high,
they never work out.
>>Galpin: Yeah, I know, I know, I know.
Or maybe I don't know.
[laughs] My feeling is I wanted the game to
grab me faster with a story and an engaging
game.
Now, the-- I'm really curious about the location-based
stuff.
There is actually-- And also with the tutorial
that really explained how to play, not to
tell you what to do.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
That would really help.
>>Galpin: I really wanted "Tap on the skeleton.
You'll find the skeleton in the map because
he's blinking in the corner."
You know?
The map will show a map of the world around
you, because we're actually in a parallel
universe, and that's what we're seeing here.
All that kind of stuff--
>>Ni-Lewis: Really, that's the whole story?
>>Galpin: I think that actually is what's
going on, but I don't--
>>Ni-Lewis: Niiiiiice.
>>Galpin: But I don't completely know.
It's a little confusing.
There's a lot-- This game really requires
probably five or six hours of deep exploration.
>>Ni-Lewis: Here's the other thing that I
just want to mention, and it's a little nit,
and wouldn't get anybody fired or anything,
but [pause] but that's the word "temples"
spelled out in Greek characters.
>>Galpin: Yeah.
>>Ni-Lewis: Temple.
>>Ni-Lewis: You know what, if you're going
to use Greek characters, learn Greek.
It's not that hard.
[pause]
>>Lucas: It is kinda hard.
>>Ni-Lewis: What?
>>Lucas: I think it's kinda hard.
>>Ni-Lewis: It's not hard at all!
>>Lucas: It is!
>>Ni-Lewis: You are Greek!
>>Galpin: [laughs]
>>Lucas: I know!
I'm speaking with authority!
>>Ni-Lewis: You're biased!
>>Galpin: Oh wait, hey, put the camera on
the Greek man, okay?
>>Meier: I actually want to ask a question,
Alex.
How old were you when you learned Greek?
>>Lucas: I don't really know Greek very well
because it's hard!
>>Galpin: [laughs]
>>Meier: Good answer.
>>Ni-Lewis: Malacca.
>>Galpin: It is Greek to him.
There we are.
All right.
So thank you for being there as our Greek
correspondent.
It's not often we get to take advantage of
that.
>>Ni-Lewis: All right.
Let's move on, because this is obviously a
deep game, but it's just so slow that I--
>>Galpin: Did you play this game, Alex, by
the way?
>>Lucas: Yeah.
>>Galpin: Any other comments you have on the
game?
>>Ni-Lewis: Alex is there.
>>Galpin: Sorry.
Any other comments you have on the game?
>>Ni-Lewis: All right.
>>Lucas: Pretty much everything that you guys
said.
I found it very slow to get started.
>>Galpin: Okay.
>>Lucas: And it was like the Lord of the Rings
thing where there's just a whole lot of walking.
It's supposed to be an adventure, but it's
90% just walking.
>>Galpin: [laughs] Without the poetry.
>>Lucas: Right, without the poetry.
>>Ni-Lewis: So there's a plus.
But other than that, yeah.
So this is something that--
>>Galpin: And it's also an online game, by
the way.
>>Ni-Lewis: Right.
>>Galpin: And I have also not yet gotten to
the really cool online features that I know
must be there, other than the chat.
>>Ni-Lewis: Well, but this is a good point.
I mean, it's true that we review five games
a week.
We don't have to time necessarily to put huge
amounts of effort into each one.
But then again, neither do the people that
you're hoping will purchase things.
If we--
>>Galpin: We have short attention spans, but
so does everyone.
>>Ni-Lewis: Everyone, yeah.
I attended a talk by John Romero last year.
As you know-- I mean-- So John is obviously
famous for--
>>Galpin: Having a short attention span?
>>Ni-Lewis: No!
>>Galpin: Oh.
>>Ni-Lewis: For Doom--
>>Galpin: I know, I know.
[laughs]
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah, for making an awesome game
called Doom and a crappy one called Daikatana.
But recently, he's been in--
>>Galpin: Hey, I killed lots of frogs in Daikatana,
okay?
>>Ni-Lewis: Lately, he's been in the Facebook
space, and he had some really, really good
things to say.
He and his wife made a game whose title escapes
me at the moment, but it is very, very popular.
And they pointed out that according to their
metrics, people gave you about 30 seconds
to a minute before they moved on to the next
thing.
>>Galpin: Wow, okay.
>>Ni-Lewis: And so no matter how deep your
game is, if you can't grab someone in that
amount of time, it's very, very unlikely that
they will give you a second thought, because
there are just so many things out there that
people can be entertained by.
Why would they work hard to be entertained
by your system, if it takes a huge amount
of grinding, when they could very easily go
to some other game and be entertained immediately?
>>Galpin: Exactly.
I just wanted to get grabbed by the story
more quickly.
Definitely the movement speed was driving
me just crazy in the game.
And also, to be honest, it's really not clear
when you're fighting.
When you click-- So there's your 'click to
move' and 'click to fight', so you have to
actually stop moving, wait for the guy to
be there, then click him once you stop moving
and he's next to you.
>>Ni-Lewis: Well, that's just a poor interface
there.
>>Galpin: I really wanted the interface to
be-- Even though I like the, in general, 'tap
to move where you want to go,' if you see
the monster's there, I really want the 'tap
to walk up and start bludgeoning'.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah, I thought that was pretty
obvious.
I mean, any mouse-based RPG, that's exactly
what you do.
If you tap on an enemy, you will move to him
and start attacking.
>>Galpin: Yeah.
Now here's what you-- That moves you to the
position.
You'll walk right through the enemy until
[coughs]
>>Ni-Lewis: That's nasty.
>>Lucas: That was the most awkward part for
me.
I'd click on the skeleton, we'd start walking
toward each other, and then pass each other.
>>Ni-Lewis: [laughs]
>>Galpin: Yeah.
>>Lucas: The skeleton turns around and starts
bludgeoning me in the back, and I just keep
walking forward like I don't care.
>>Ni-Lewis: Wow, that's like Starcraft UI.
All right.
You know what?
We're just going to get madder and madder
the further we go with this.
Let's talk about Patentia, which I actually
really enjoy.
>>Galpin: Patentia's super clever.
I love--
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
The guy said it was his first game.
>>Galpin: Yeah.
>>Ni-Lewis: And it's certainly a simple game,
but it's very well executed.
So the idea with Patentia is that you're going
to--
>>Galpin: You can even switch-- There we are,
yeah, exactly.
>>Ni-Lewis: You're going to go ahead and draw
a shape.
These are mostly-- They start out as Tetris
shapes--
>>Galpin: Most of them are tetrominos.
>>Ni-Lewis: But you can draw them in any orientation.
Which honestly was the one thing I didn't
like, because it meant I had to do a lot of
drawing, and sometimes I'd get it wrong.
But as an interface, there's a couple things
that are really good about it.
First, it's very reactive.
It's got this particle system which means
absolutely nothing, but it's kinda cool.
And it shows you where you're drawing.
It's just really, really good at that.
And then, what's clever about it is you're
trying to fill space so no matter what shape
things are, the idea is you need to put them
together so that you can get these things
through.
And if you wait for these--
>>Galpin: You're trying to create rectangles
or squares.
That's your goal.
>>Ni-Lewis: Right.
And you're trying to fill the entirety of
the board.
And if you can make it a square, for instance,
like this, well, almost like that-- Let's
see, I think I-- All right, I'm going to need
a new shape there.
[pause] [clicking sounds] Darn it.
See, this is where I would love to have better
[pause] intelligence of some kind.
Why am I-- Everything I draw doesn't work.
Okay, there we go.
All right.
>>Galpin: Yeah.
It's--
>>Ni-Lewis: Help me out here, man.
>>Galpin: You have to think about that block.
You can only draw it in the four rotated orientations
of that block.
>>Ni-Lewis: Right.
>>Galpin: So you can't-- Unfortunately, it's
a little-- You do have to think back to the
block and it's physical shape rather than
just it's-- You can't draw its flipped orientation,
basically.
>>Ni-Lewis: Right, exactly.
You have to just draw it rotated, and so for
me, because I'm handicapped that way, it was
a little more difficult.
Which is weird, because I did so well on the
ASVAB spatial rotation stuff.
I don't know, maybe it's just-- Anyway--
>>Galpin: I blame the alcohol right now.
>>Ni-Lewis: Right, there you go.
Now, I'm going to-- See, that made me a huge
rectangle.
And one thing that's kinda cool about this
is that while that rectangle's building, I
can actually make it bigger.
>>Galpin: Yeah, that is really cool.
>>Ni-Lewis: I don't know if that actually
helps anything, but I can do it.
And then as long as I wait for it to fill
up, it gives me more score.
Now, that doesn't seem like a big deal on
a level like this, but in a level where you
have very little space, and very little time,
that's kinda a big deal.
Do you wait for it to fill up, or do you tap
it immediately to get less score but more
space?
As you go on, the levels get more and more
difficult.
And you start moving from these tetrominos
to more and more weird and interesting shapes.
Some of them are quite frustrating, and very
large gameboard.
So actually, I think I have to admit, after
several hours of play, I think I ended up
crapping out on level four or five, which
is was just gigantic.
It was almost impossible to fill in the time
they gave you.
>>Galpin: Let's see.
I thought I-- I know I was drawing that correctly,
so it just didn't register my draw.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
The other thing that's interesting is that
you'll notice that some of these little blocks
have cracks in them.
And that becomes important later on because
those will get removed if you don't have space.
>>Galpin: Ohhhh, nice.
>>Ni-Lewis: Those are what they call "leftovers",
which are just-- Once you've drawn something,
if part of the shape forms a rectangle, and
the rest of them don't, like these two right
here--
>>Galpin: Gotcha.
>>Ni-Lewis: Those are now going to turn into
leftovers.
And if you run out of space, those will get
removed.
And if that happens, you'll get more space,
but your score multiplier will get reset.
Right now, you're at a score multiplier of
two.
And it would get reset back to one.
>>Galpin: "Next board unlocked."
>>Ni-Lewis: Right, and that's because you
covered 50% of the board or more.
So you can tell this--
>>Galpin: I thought this game was totally
clear.
We're both-- You know.
I would like to see them get rid of the compatibility
button in the zoom and the zoom thing and
target--
>>Ni-Lewis: If you look down at the bottom
of the screen, you can see a lot of things
going wrong that shouldn't be going wrong.
But overall-- And of course, on this Asus
Transformer Prime, the UI up in the upper
left-hand corner is much smaller than it needs
to be.
It's verging on not being readable.
You also do need a pretty hefty manual.
I had to reread the instructions several times
before I understood what was going on.
And I would say that a more professional game
would have introduced all of the concepts
to me via tutorials rather than just throwing
me into the--
>>Galpin: The only reason I know what I was
doing was that I watched the video.
And that was super, super helpful.
But I agree.
>>Ni-Lewis: See, that's the thing.
I never watch videos.
Why?
Because they're a complete waste of time.
Why would anyone watch a video?
[laughs] All right!
>>Galpin: So.
This is low on battery.
>>Ni-Lewis: We'd better get to the end.
Fortunately, we're almost to the next game.
Okay.
>>Galpin: We didn't bring the charger.
>>Ni-Lewis: Right.
Yeah, Patentia-- Oh, look at that.
Patentia had good [pause] feature graphic.
"Block dropping puzzle game reinvention for
touchscreen" will not be legible if Patentia
is featured on a phone.
So that's one thing that you want to look
out for.
>>Galpin: Also, that icon, really?
Do we really need a rounded rectangle for
that?
>>Ni-Lewis: No, you don't at all, actually.
No.
>>Galpin: I love to see you come up with some
other theme, other than--
>>Ni-Lewis: Well, at least it's not as bad
as the Offroad Legends icon, which has chrome
around it.
Although, since it's about monster trucks,
I'll allow the chrome.
>>Galpin: Yeah.
And actually, I like the fact that the dust
actually covers up the chrome as if it were
real.
>>Ni-Lewis: That is cool.
It should pop out, right.
>>Galpin: Oh, yeah.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
These guys-- Now, the Offroad Legends icon
there, or the title, should be larger for
a feature graphic.
We usually recommend that it covers about
50% of the available pixels.
So it should be twice as big.
>>Galpin: It's got to be at least a third
the height of it.
If it's smaller than a third the height of
it, we say it's going to be illegible.
I would say if it were a good 25% bigger,
it would be the minimum acceptable size there.
>>Ni-Lewis: This is Offroad Legend by Dog
bite games.
I mean, how much more masculine can you get?
>>Galpin: Exactly, exactly.
Actually, I really like their other game.
It's 8 bit Ninja.
>>Ni-Lewis: [laughs]
>>Galpin: It made my kinda laugh as I was
looking.
>>Ni-Lewis: It's very awesome.
>>Galpin: This is a fairly radically different
kind of game.
We'll actually bring it up.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah, let's take a look at this.
Offroad Legends' is a very polished game.
>>Galpin: Let's bring up a scoreloop and say,
"Hello!
Do you like fun?"
>>Ni-Lewis: No, scoreloop doesn't ask if you
like fun.
>>Galpin: No, I know it doesn't.
Oh, no, no, it's bringing up Tapjoy ads.
All right.
>>Ni-Lewis: Really?
>>Galpin: Yeah.
>>Ni-Lewis: Oh.
I didn't get hit with that.
Maybe my--
>>Galpin: Oooh, I do like that.
>>Ni-Lewis: What?
>>Galpin: Is that not the awesome--
>>Ni-Lewis: That is pretty sweet.
>>Galpin: I know.
>>Ni-Lewis: It's not exactly a monster truck,
though.
>>Galpin: I know.
There we are.
>>Ni-Lewis: You've got quite an accomplished
garage, my friend.
>>Galpin: No, that's 'cause I pretend to go
and review the game.
You get that if you hit the--
>>Ni-Lewis: They gave you an incentive for
reviewing the game?
>>Galpin: Yeah!
They didn't actually say what kind of--
>>Ni-Lewis: [exhales] Get a room.
>>Galpin: They didn't say what kind of review
to give.
>>Ni-Lewis: Oh, that's a good point.
>>Galpin: They just said, "Review the game
and get this."
I'm like, "Cool," so I clicked the button
and then I went back.
And I got this, which is kinda awesome.
[rustling and scraping sounds] Okay.
>>Ni-Lewis: Go ahead.
[more rustling and scraping]
>>Galpin: Okay.
Now the bummer is that I can't actually choose
that bus for the monster warm-up.
>>Ni-Lewis: Oh, that sucks!
>>Galpin: I know, I know.
But this game has got pretty good visuals.
For the style of game it is, which is kinda
this web style of track--
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah, it's like a four button--
Basically.
>>Meier: I have to ask: are the wheels on
the truck filled with helium, 'cause I'm not
sure that those physics are legit.
>>Galpin: I don't think this game--
>>Ni-Lewis: That's because you don't live
in America, my friend.
>>Meier: [laughs]
>>Galpin: [laughs] Whoohoo!
>>Ni-Lewis: You'll learn.
>>Galpin: Yeah.
Monster-- This has monster truck physics.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
>>Galpin: It's the kind of physics we invented
here.
>>Ni-Lewis: Monster trucks are completely
different from other trucks.
They're monstrous.
The thing--
>>Galpin: Oh yeah, there we are.
You have to have gratuitous and unnecessary
pictures of people who look like Danica Patrick
in your game.
>>Ni-Lewis: That's right.
Americaaaaa!
>>Galpin: I'm thinking Go Daddy right now.
I don't know why.
>>Ni-Lewis: Right?
I'm thinking that half of the racing games
in the world, honestly.
But I'll tell you what sets this apart is
not only do they have a fairly good set of--
not perfect.
The presentation is not perfect.
There is a few cheesy icons--
>>Galpin: It's a little busy at times.
>>Ni-Lewis: --and some gradients that look
really, really out of place.
But in general, especially in the game, it
looks great.
And unlike many of the racing games we've
reviewed, they have some great crash physics.
>>Galpin: They really, really do.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
Yeah, give us a crash.
Give us a crash.
Crash for daddy.
Boom!
No, that's not a crash.
>>Galpin: That was a bad crash.
Well, this is a good one.
There we are.
Boom!
Oh, there we are!
>>Ni-Lewis: Ah, there you go!
Yeah!
>>Galpin: Yeah, that's a good one.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
Yeah, I don't know-- The truck is a little
better, I think, than the car.
I think they have a better crash model.
>>Galpin: They do, they do.
>>Ni-Lewis: But yeah.
Now, they do have some weird physics.
And it is actually possible to lose a wheel
without ending the race.
>>Galpin: Oh, wow, that's cool.
>>Ni-Lewis: I know this because last night,
I lost three wheels and was unable to do anything.
But the race was still on.
You know why?
[pause] America.
>>Galpin: Absolutely.
>>Ni-Lewis: [laughs] So-- Whoa!
That is awesome.
>>Galpin: I think that's actually the first
time you've ever sworn on the program.
>>Ni-Lewis: What?
>>Galpin: I think, I think.
Did I swear?
>>Galpin: [laughs] I know, I know.
Shocking.
>>Ni-Lewis: I totally--
>>Galpin: You sang the song from--
>>Ni-Lewis: No I didn't!
>>Galpin: Okay.
>>Ni-Lewis: No, that happened inside your
head.
>>Galpin: Oh, okay, okay, it might have.
>>Ni-Lewis: Weird.
>>Galpin: Ooooh, there we are.
Finally I get to use my bus.
Yaaaaay!
>>Lucas: I think there's auto complete profanity.
[laughs]
>>Ni-Lewis: That's possible.
>>Lucas: He talks and we just fill in the
f-bombs.
>>Galpin: Whoohoo! [pause] So yeah.
I don't know what else to say on this game.
I believe this game also plays audio on the
lock screen, as I recall.
>>Ni-Lewis: [laughs] I'm going to give it
a pass.
>>Lucas: [laughs]
>>Meier: Would that be because "America"?
>>Ni-Lewis: Exactly!
Because of America, that's why!
>>Galpin: Oooh, man.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah, check that out!
See, the race is still on.
>>Galpin: Dude, there's nothing I can do.
Can I put the tires back on? [all laugh]
>>Ni-Lewis: I don't know, maybe that's an
in-app purchase.
>>Lucas: [laughs]
>>Ni-Lewis: It totally should be.
>>Galpin: Gaaah!
How do I manipulate my car anymore?
>>Meier: Can you in-app purchase an RAC membership
for that service?
>>Galpin: I guess I can.
Wow, this is pretty sad.
>>Ni-Lewis: [laughs] Nice.
>>Galpin: All right, all right, all right.
Restart.
It looks like we're going to run out of battery
just at the right time here.
>>Ni-Lewis: Oh, we're already overtime.
But this was a great game.
>>Galpin: Yeah, it's totally fine.
>>Ni-Lewis: It's not everybody's cup of tea.
It's honestly, all joking aside, probably
not my cup of tea.
There's a few things that I would love to
change about it.
I feel like the--
>>Galpin: Ahhh!
>>Ni-Lewis: --the difficulty is just wrong.
It's not easy enough to get big air, yet it's
too easy to land small jumps.
There's not a lot of skill involved.
And maybe it's just me, because I live in
the Bay Area and for all my bragging, I know
nothing about monster truck physics, but--
Nice!
Okay, now, see, that's the thing!
Right there, I'll tell you what really needs
to happen: you need an achievement.
You need something that pops up and says,
"Pancake!"
>>Galpin: That's so true.
>>Meier: [laughs]
>>Galpin: Yeah, 'cause that actually-- that
takes--
>>Ni-Lewis: You know what?
Everything that I was saying that was critical,
I take it all back.
'Cause that was awesome.
That was so awesome.
All right, you know what?
Let's go ahead and--
>>Galpin: We're never going-- I can already
tell that Ian's never going driving with me
again.
This is-- I have demonstrated--
>>Ni-Lewis: I never drive with you.
You drive a Prius.
>>Galpin: That's true, actually.
>>Ni-Lewis: [laughs] All right.
>>Galpin: Never again are we doing monster
trucks together.
>>Lucas: Is it an offroading Prius?
>>Galpin: That's true.
That would be kinda awesome, to get the jacked
up Prius.
>>Ni-Lewis: How would you know the difference?
>>Galpin: The diff-- Whoohoo!
>>Ni-Lewis: Oh yeah, you could.
>>Lucas: Spray-on mud.
>>Ni-Lewis: Nice.
>>Galpin: Whoa!
There we are!
All right!
>>Ni-Lewis: Boom! [music playing] That's it!
All right.
>>Galpin: Just after I made it through the
jump.
>>Ni-Lewis: Oh, oh, oh!
>>Galpin: Oh, nice.
>>Ni-Lewis: Oh, yeah, I forgot.
I did this for Dan.
Watch.
We're done!
Brrrr [makes exploding noise]
>>Galpin: Oh man, flame effects.
That's awesome.
And that worked so well after Offroad.
That was cool.
>>Ni-Lewis: Right?
>>Galpin: Yeah.
Well definitely, I can't wait to see what
you do with aftereffects now.
We could--
>>Ni-Lewis: I know, right?
It's going to be incredible.
All right.
>>Galpin: Wait, wait, wait, look.
Check this out.
What happened?
>>Ni-Lewis: I poured myself a second glass.
>>Galpin: Oh, okay.
I was going to say!
>>Lucas: And he poured me zero.
>>Galpin: You've not given Alex any beer yet?
[scoffs]
>>Lucas: I'm going to be sober.
>>Galpin: Wow.
>>Lucas: Hurts.
>>Galpin: Yeah, I know.
>>Lucas: This is why I've been randomly muting
you throughout the show.
>>Galpin: [laughs]
>>Ni-Lewis: Makes sense-- did-- So Alex, producer
Alex, how did the YouTube comment stream go?
>>Galpin: Yes.
>>Lucas: Actually, we have, from the developer
of Pearls, who's also invited the developer
of Vision of the Veggies, which we reviewed
a couple months ago.
>>Ni-Lewis: Right.
>>Galpin: Oh!
>>Lucas: He says he updated the feature graphic,
and it should be up soon.
>>Ni-Lewis: Awesome!
>>Lucas: And he'd like to get our feedback.
It doesn't look like it's refreshed yet, but
as far as developers and apps we've reviewed
on this show, he's by far the fastest turnaround
load, the fastest feedback loop.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah, yeah.
Rock on.
>>Lucas: While we-- This is the second time
while we comment on the thing.
He says, "Hey, I can fix that."
>>Ni-Lewis: Nice.
Well, I think it's a good game.
>>Galpin: Yeah, it is.
>>Ni-Lewis: And it's one of those games that's--
>>Galpin: It's hard, actually.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
It's fun to pick and-- Well actually, that's
a good point.
Actually, if you're still listening: bubble
popping games are incredibly popular, and
they are-- Hey Reto, you can switch to me
anytime you want.
>>Lucas: I'm the prettier one.
>>Galpin: I actually kinda like it on Alex.
>>Meier: You get some of the best [inaudible].
>>Lucas: [laughs]
>>Galpin: Yeah, in fact, we're totally scoring
points with our Greek audience now.
>>Ni-Lewis: Gotcha.
Anyway.
What I was trying to say is, if you're still
listening: the bubble popping game audience
skews older, female, and is almost certainly
not an audience that's looking for a really
high stress game.
Also, I play them a lot, despite not being
female.
Or [pause] anyway.
The point is--
>>Galpin: You use it to de-stress.
It's my moment of Zen.
>>Ni-Lewis: The point is that you do need
to make sure you've got a learning curve on
these things that isn't going to completely
frustrate your audience.
>>Galpin: Yeah, I would say that was my one
comment about the game, was I wanted there
to be an "ease you in" moment.
And because of the design of the puzzles,
it is actually tricky to do that.
But I think it's possible.
>>Ni-Lewis: Well, the other thing that I would
suggest that I think would improve the game
is it did take me a few times before I understood
what the rules were of drawing the line through
the pearls.
And the game does a pretty good job of it.
>>Galpin: It does, actually.
>>Ni-Lewis: It's not bad.
But I think it could really be improved with
a few examples where you actually just draw
the line for the user.
>>Galpin: Yeah, definitely, definitely.
>>Ni-Lewis: All right.
Anything else on the YouTube there, Alex?
Producer Alex?
Executive Producer Alex?
>>Lucas: All's quiet on the YouTube front.
>>Galpin: All right.
>>Ni-Lewis: Well, you guys suck. [laughs]
All right.
So that's our show for today.
>>Galpin: We abuse our audience.
That's what we do here on the Friday Game
Review.
>>Lucas: Oh actually--
>>Ni-Lewis: That's exactly what we do.
>>Lucas: Igor says, "I think I'll be getting
hammered tonight.
Sorry, not me.
I was thinking of Ian.
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah!
>>Galpin: Oooh, yeah!
>>Ni-Lewis: All right.
Who's got two thumbs and needs to go to AA?
>>Galpin: [squeaks]
>>Lucas: That guy.
>>Ni-Lewis: No. [laughs] All right.
Actually, I've been babysitting my baby daughter
all week.
My wife is out of town.
She's in Shanghai on business.
>>Galpin: Hopefully she's bringing you some
cool stuff back for the household?
>>Ni-Lewis: Well, I hope so.
I could use some more of those ceramic knives,
I'll tell you that much.
>>Galpin: Yeah, those ceramic knives were
kickass.
>>Ni-Lewis: Weren't they good?
>>Galpin: Yeah, really good.
>>Ni-Lewis: All right.
>>Galpin: It's a pack for me.
>>Ni-Lewis: [laughs] All right.
Well, that is our show.
Thanks very much for joining us on the Friday
Games Review.
We will be back next week with another open
topic.
We'll see how this goes.
>>Galpin: Yeah.
There was a lot of other stuff in the topic
from this week, too.
>>Ni-Lewis: Right.
Just remember that, unlike before, we are
refreshing the topic each week.
So if you nominate something this week and
it didn't get chosen, you do need to renominate
it for next week in order for it to be considered
again.
>>Galpin: Absolutely.
And we'll probably at some point have some
themes as well, again.
I think the current thought is that we'll
actually always take some random games, so
we don't have to have someone who waits for
six months 'til we get back to the theme again.
Because a lot of people want us to look at
their games.
But also, we do really, really like the idea
of being able to theme some of the shows.
>>Ni-Lewis: We've also talked about a few
other options.
I'd love to get some feedback from our viewers.
>>Galpin: Absolutely.
>>Ni-Lewis: For instance, we've discussed
the possibility of talking about the games
that are going to be featured that week, and
why they were featured, and what they have
in common.
>>Galpin: Exactly.
>>Ni-Lewis: We've talked about maybe looking
at games from unknown developers, or maybe
even previewing games from known developers
that you might be excited about.
Let us know what you're interested in.
We'd love to make this show more valuable
to you.
>>Galpin: Yeah.
What I really want, actually, at some point,
is to do a show where people nominate games
that they wish were better.
Wouldn't that be kinda cool?
>>Ni-Lewis: That would be an excellent-- And
that's one thing that we have talked about
doing: maybe a game clinic.
'Cause we have plenty of tools here.
We look at games in very in depth ways all
the time, trying to figure out how their draw
order and their texturing and their resources
and their geometry affects their performance.
>>Galpin: How can we make this game suck less?
>>Ni-Lewis: Yeah.
>>Galpin: We do that all the time.
>>Ni-Lewis: We would love to switch into that
mode, I think.
>>Galpin: Absolutely.
>>Ni-Lewis: Let us know what you think.
And to all our drunk friends in Austria: "Hey."
And-- Cool, do you want to do mirror?
>>Galpin: Yeah!
>>Ni-Lewis: All right.
Anyway, it's been good chatting with you on
the Friday Game Review.
And we will see you next week at our new time.
Right?
We have a new time?
>>Galpin: Do we have a new time?
Sure.
>>Ni-Lewis: Next week.
Make sure you check our Google+ page, because
there may be a new time.
>>Galpin: May be a new time.
>>Ni-Lewis: And if there is, you do not want
to miss that.
>>Galpin: That's right.
All right, thanks everyone.
>>Ni-Lewis: Take care.
[electronic music playing]